außerdem falls ihr jetzt die soll laut
ok den aus neue projekt auch wieder
kaputt keine sorge in den arm was kaputt
machen sollte gibt's zu einer super band
gap bei uns nicht kaputt aber raus die
erste nicht kaputte waschmaschinen leben
leben länger mit ok falls jetzt hier
gerade steht und wir sind in der neuen
folge haben wahrscheinlich gerade kraft
gesetzt war schon bei 18 uhr noch raus
waren also nach zehn minuten schon war
ja also falls wir hier einen neuen folge
sind seid ihr willkommen vielleicht ist
es auch hat mitten in anderen folge das
testurteil wir sind immer noch in der
gleichen folge ich hab keine ahnung und
ihr seid einfach nur einer macht 30
minuten folge das umgekehrt auch jetzt
nicht auch alle wirklich die 80 minuten
folge machen müsse dass alle genau der
stelle schneiden man ganz genau was das
eigentlich ein blog den du hier in
berlin gesetzt hast dass das ist das was
mich gekillt hatte naja das ist dieses
trios ding weil sie auch noch ansprechen
wollte das auf jeden fall
ich glaube es sollte dann auch
entsprechend viele sagen öfters so das
megaprojekt war früher geil und wird
immer schlechter oder irgendwie sowas
so kann es natürlich darauf
zurückzuführen sein dass jetzt natürlich
viel mist gebaut wurde aber anders jetzt
so einfach so leute müsse sich überlegen
es ist so wir haben einfach alles schon
sozusagen fast ja alles was man so
erreichen kann so gut wie erreicht
endlos jupiter jeder cloud von einem
judith rakers braucht dann entscheidet
man sich alles so mit jedem meter her
dann haben wir können unsere geräte
aufladen und wir haben dem monster falle
die rund 30 erfahrung gibt so und kann
so das ist so es ist halt nicht sie
haben einfach bei ticket bzw
dabei finde biest also bei diesen ganzen
sachen wo sie technisch aufbereitet
da hat man einfach irgendwann und auch
mal wieder hat man einfach das ist mir
ja schwer als aber irgendwann hat man
alles und wenn man dann alles hat denn
dann ist nichts mehr eine
herausforderung ändert dahin knapp schon
mal mit einem schlag weg das macht man
einfach so dann kann es eben nicht mehr
genauso sein
ist es halt manchmal denn dann ist auch
halt manchmal so dann will man auch
einfach mal vielleicht irgendwo was was
neu macht der autor sache geeinigt
gemacht sondern auch bemerkt irgendwie
doch nicht so cool immer alles hat und
plötzlich nichts mehr hat aber dass es
ist wir können die zeit nicht
zurückdrehen so sagen wir spielen seit
seit fast vier monaten glaube ich
mittlerweile oder zwei alle dreieinhalb
monate und das war megageil die meisten
im über 100 folgen ausschuss schon fast
100 folgen und das war mir egal aber
nicht ewig laufen wir sind nicht krank
und machen 1000 folgen das kann dass das
passt auch nicht immer
es kann ja wenn man wenn man möchte ganz
so weiter also kann es ja für die leute
weiter lust haben sich sozusagen in an
frischen ewig laufen aber ich sage mal
ganz ehrlich als zuschauer müsste sagt
mal ihr könnt ihr mal ehrlich einfach
sagen wollt ihr einfach ein projekt
einfach nur bei sein projekt ist was ihr
schon so lange habt was man kennt
einfach das endlos weiter läuft oder
wollte einfach mal was neues gleich ist
also ich persönlich bin jemand ich würde
einfach gerne mal was neues starten ich
würde gerne einfach mal auch abwechslung
ich brauche also ich persönlich bin
soweit komm mal abwechslung zwischen
jetzt ist so am anfang waren alles so
neumann hat als er forscht war also guck
mal ist das schon sehen und unter erste
juli meter und eine ruine und so gerne
und dann auch hier gibt es falle und
boah krass und es war alles so neu jetzt
ist für uns alles so dass wir kennen es
leid ist für uns sozusagen ein anschluss
ist der sehen vor allem die leute auch
immer auf unsere kanälen dass wir jetzt
auch mehr so kanäle sind jetzt nicht so
krank wie jetzt einfach mal 1000 2000
3000 wird auf 12.000 folgen von dem
projekt macht sondern wir sind also
leute ja damals adventure web dann war
hier noch ein bisschen pvp sondern mal
so paar neue sachen halt so viele leute
zusammen so viele folgen gemacht das ist
schon richtig krass wie viel geschafft
haben so das sagt euch auf euren ohren
so dass plötzlich beendet oder irgendwie
sowas wird auch nicht mehr geändert es
wird manche leute für vielleicht fangen
noch sei es also also fangen manche sind
auch gar nicht dazu gekommen oder so und
die fangen jetzt zusammenzubauen und ich
ehrlich gesagt wenn in der letzten folge
habe habe ich erst gemerkt so zu bauen
so und man ich finde auch dass beim er
prägt hat mir am anfang gesagt dass ich
keinen projekt sein was jeden tag sonst
so
immer mal wieder und dann machen wir es
jetzt auch so dass immer mal wieder
kommt oder was wir machen es jetzt das
bleibt jedem weiter freigestellt oder im
bock hat macht mal wieder jeden tag eine
folge und einmal jede woche und noch
gesehen den zweiten ganz wie man möchte
sagt meist beispiel indem ich sag mal
dieses neue let's play was doch nebenbei
geplant das ist ja überhaupt nicht dass
es mehrere ablösen soll auf keinen fall
ist einfach nebenbei geplant so wie zb
conny macht mit mit sonic sei denn
nebenbei ist ja auch nicht so dass leute
die sich beschweren erfolg unfair
du machst die male dabei so was machen
einfach einzelne projekte ist es einfach
nur nebenbei
oder es ist auch keine rudolfskai dann
machen wir lieber megaprojekt weiter
oder oder ja mach mal du machst du
machst träume mitgemacht megaprojekt so
weiß ich meine das ist ja auch so und
das wird auch einfach nur die händler
klampen app genau am 1 und wenn wenn
wenn wenn wenn jetzt jemand einfach wenn
es nicht so wäre
der hat momentan zum beispiel auch
gesagt er möchte einfach generell
momentan vielleicht meine kleine was
etwas neues ausprobieren so es ist
überhaupt mich dass diese projekte
moment überhaupt das projekt nicht
kommen wird das neue dann würde auch
einfach genauso sein sohn deswegen also
ist einfach etwas komplett überhaupt
nichts damit zu tun hat ist das komplett
eigenständiges und zum beispiel den und
conny sind zum beispiel zum beispiel mal
zu verraten zwei leute die unter
umständen dabei sein könnte man weiß es
nicht vielleicht noch viele andere leute
ist alles noch ein geheimnis
und wie viele leute dabei sind wir noch
nicht ganz genau so ist es so dass das
wir überlegen also sind sechs leute pro
stadt sind sieben leute pro stadt sind
vielleicht wenn heute noch bestrafen ist
man weiß ja nicht wer sein mit wem in
der stadt weil manche leute möchten
vielleicht zusammen sein aber vielleicht
auch bei denen vielleicht möchten sie
auch gar nicht und man muss ja auch
irgendwie wir wollen das natürlich also
das ist soll der plan hier zum beispiel
bekam das team mäßiges gemacht so und
als das team astana profis einmal haus
eingeladen so dann haben leute sogar
sich beschwert doch für unfair roth bist
hat war einfach eine falsche sachen dazu
bekommen so man kann es irgendwie die
leute nie recht machen
das ist so man kann man haben sie ein
recht machen weißt du worüber ich mich
freuen das aber nicht nur bei mega
projekt so dass es bei allen sachen
geben wird im wagen würden dass es
trotzdem blöd vor allem jetzt auch auf
den er noch mal bezogen mit der sache es
wird immer noch leute geben die sagen
nee ich fand das von denen einfach nicht
akzeptabel aber damit muss man dann halt
einfach leben so und ich die sache ich
meine ist worauf ich mich einfach freuen
würde es wenn jetzt einfach mal auf euch
zukommen lassen
negative vorahnung sein so ich freue
mich darauf was kommt wenn wir das
verpacken könnt ihr uns wirklich sagen
hey beste dass ihr habt es war eine gute
idee aber die umsetzung war vielleicht
nicht so gut aber glaubt mir das wird
nicht passieren denn da sind einige
sachen geplant und es wird es wird geil
ist gab viele elemente die von mega
punkt wo wir auch dazugelernt habe es
mir auch sachen wo wir so viel gelernt
haben weil er war aber einfach einem
projekt wodurch man auch lernen konnte
ich hätte es genauso wie in der ersten
beziehung wenn man mit irgendeinem
mädels zusammen sowieso man lernt so
viel mit irgendwelchen dingen umzugehen
sei es irgendwie keine ahnung wieso was
das ist halt genauso mit mega projekt
das wasser und es war nicht ein test
aber man hat sich dieses megaprojekt
sehr viel gelernt es waren super geil
das projekt und man hat eine menge
dadurch gelernt und man lernt immer noch
neues dadurch ist ein projekt was mit
mehr als 100 folgen hatte das ist es
hätte noch generell noch nie langes
letzte projekt so dass einziges
verbrechen hatte balkon crafter vorher
fließt also das war das waren 30
klaus war ja im gesunden dreh und wir
haben auch nichts mit viel zustande
bekommen dadurch hierdurch habe mir das
erst einmal vertiefen können und zwar
alles möglich man hat schnell gelernt
ebenso klein beispiel durch dieses
projekt von euch kam er überhaupt erst
das megaprojekt so kann überhaupt dass
die ids auf macs zu machen
basieren auf durch unser features mehr
abbrechen soll das megaprojekt kommt
wieder neue ideen und zum beispiel diese
dass so viele leute gefallen so ich habe
diese kleinen kriege oder auch
verschiedene lager und so das sind alles
sachen die das megaprojekt gekommen sind
wo er wieder neue ideen kommen und ihr
solltet auch nicht denken dass alles
jetzt irgendwie neu aufgeschüttet wird
ein paar sachen bleiben natürlich auch
gleich
von daher sollte dieses ist es dieses
dieses krieg von den lagern so es solche
dass drei städte gibt entweder den
frieden im krieg das alles lasse ich mal
was wird das wird wirklich geil könnt
ihr könnt es auch konstruktive
vorschläge machen was ihr euch wünschen
wordpress projekt wir sind für uns immer
super offen und und wir wollen einfach
nur das was unser ziel ist wir wollen
einfach nur geil preetz auf die bayern
stellen wo wir viele leute unterhalten
können wohl leider seien viele denken so
wie geil heute wieder ich freue mich die
freude und so und das megaprojekt mit
meiner meinung an dem punkt angekommen
wo ich persönlich für mich sagen muss
ich hatte schon ein bevor ich die
technik gemacht habe ich schon vor
technik ist nicht so mein fall
und das ist einfach wirklich so ich habe
dieses ständige kräfte kräfte kräfte
kräfte ist jetzt nichts mehr
mega viel spaß macht aber genau das ist
das gute megaprojekt manche finden das
super treu manche nicht und jeder hat
verschiedene wege eingeschlagen lieber
bücher in vier verschiedene sachen macht
so und das ist ja das gute und ist
genauso einem neuen projekt auch wieder
kommen und wir haben wieder viele leute
dabei wird es wird sehr lustig ich freue
mich natürlich wenn noch ein paar leute
dazukommen den noch gar nicht gerechnet
haben und weiß noch nicht genau was dann
kommt einfach abwarten und überraschen
lassen
genauso sieht aus als ob also ich freue
mich darauf ich arbeite wirklich ein
hochamt mit hochtouren daran dass alles
auf die beine zu stellen und nicht
bestätigen
den haben stehen es ist wirklich viel
arbeit und ja respektiert das einfach
und wartet dann mal ab und dann werdet
schon sehen was dabei rumkommt und vor
allem jetzt nicht irgendwie weiter sagen
so von wegen sondern etwa mit einer
guten einstellung jetzt daran gehen
einfach mal so sagen hey da kommt etwas
neues so von wegen
viele lange jetzt einfach so was wie zum
beispiel als beispiel als ich aufs neue
projekt angesprochen hatte so hat den
auf gar keinen fall ein neues kaputt und
dann muss einfach sagen das ist einfach
quatsch den er hat einmal was richtig
großes gemacht wo sowas zu schaden kommt
aber dafür haben sich bislang absolut
nichts immer inhalt guckt sich die 70
folgen so ist 74 dann dann erst kommt
euch erst das ange findet dann sarah
dann kommentiert ja genau und nachdem
man chaos war und bei mir andauernd
unnötig was zerstört wird auch der ok
gut dann bei den zerstörer hat mein gott
ich wollte ja nicht die anderen sachen
zerstören oder so etwas war kacke und da
ich mich auch mehrfach entschuldigt und
komme und so oft sie sich auf seine
sachen in game mode wieder zusammenbauen
simon auch das ist im endeffekt ist
wieder alles okay und für abgeschlossen
die sache ist einfach die dena wird
wirklich von einer seite so angemacht
und so und der hat auch natürlich sieht
auch ein sodass das deine aktion ein
bisschen über die stränge geschlagen ist
was ein bisschen schon über die stränge
schlagen ist aber es war nicht so
beabsichtigen er hat auch mich immer was
geträumt hatte sich vereinfacht es
prickelt dreier von den 100
es war von den reaktionen aktienreaktion
ganz normal
thumbs und du kannst du vorher schon
sachen gemacht und so und da das auch
dann hält und dann ist auch wieder so
wisse jeder jeder hat schon mal
irgendwie quatschen projekt also
weil viele haben schon projekte bisschen
quatsch und ein bisschen ist auch okay
und natürlich viele haben gesagt so dass
der impfstoff war ein bisschen zu viel
das kann man natürlich zu sehen das was
er gemacht hat war auch schon heftig
sagt mal aber ich denke jeder lernst du
ein bisschen aus fehlern und ich sag mal
so den er fand einfach super ungerecht
dass derjenige der sein haus die luft
gesprengt hat einfach nichts keine gier
keine ist kann nichts darauf den zurück
aber der ist dann derjenige der an
gemacht wird für alles zu weisen
deswegen also das ist nicht so dass der
nicht weiß was er tut oder so dass es
das ist einfach nur just for fun und er
wird so etwas auch nicht mehr machen
hatte er letzten seite wird die mega
brücken jeder irgendwas die luft
sprengen und so und der wird doch kein
training mehr machen und denkt rowling
habe ich nie gemacht ich hab mich nie
irgendwie was zerstört und dann gedacht
you're all das wird eine witzige aktion
das haben sich die leute quasi immer
irgendwie eingeredet damit sie noch
irgendwas hatten um gegen den royalen
kann was aber auch nicht irgendwie
stimmt deswegen verstehe ich dass er
nicht von den leuten hier von euch jetzt
mal ganz ehrlich und so schaukelt sich
anhalt hoch und aber passiert gehört
dazu so ist es eben
ja also ich ja ich wollte sagen ich
verzaubern wir noch ebenen buch warte
ich habe zu meinem problem was machst du
jetzt eingehend über den rs awesome bis
jetzt in dieser folge am wenigsten zu
wort gekommen weil ich so viel aber
madonna die wahl zugestimmt die ganze
zeit den knopf sagst du sagst du letzten
worte was hältst du alles verändert nach
voll von der ganzen sache wie ich vorhin
sowieso angestellten aber ich glaube das
thema ist aber ein schon ehrlich ich hab
halt nie wollte nie jemanden schaden
ich wollte nie irgendjemanden das
irgendwie hier was kaputt man so ich
habe mich immer meisten wir ganzen kripo
löcher in der stadt aufgeregt und habe
immer selbst gepflegt hier will ich auch
gar nicht ich diesen überall creeper
löcher und dass das was uns am anfang
aufgeregt hat jetzt sind es riesiger
turm grata oder oder sonstiges und auch
was so wann een och ich hab viele
zuschauer die das projekt noch viel viel
ernster als wir selbst ist noch niemand
das ist ein bisschen das
ganz so schwer ist ein bisschen falsch
aus tut also wenig das projekt jeder
wahrscheinlich auch mal ernst aber wir
nehmen es nicht so ernst dass wir sagen
was im spiel passiert da hat man es auch
wieder für so werden jetzt mal irgendwas
kaputt gemacht hat zb bei com oder so
kommen war natürlich spiel sauer aber im
echten leben kommen wir alle compper mit
einer noch nicht also im gegenteil
also ich habe ganze auch glocken ist
haben sie dachten darf also das zusammen
mit denen unterwegs sind kartfahren
alles locker leute irgendwie hat bei mir
übernachtet meine waschmaschine
zusammengebaut also was uns gibt's nicht
irgendwie so streit irgendwie solchen
aktionen gar nicht und das als junger
mann schon dass man differenzieren
für uns kommt es vielleicht doch
selbstverständlich über vielleicht ihr
seht hat nur die video ausschnitte und
ihr denkt euch hatte die mystische
stimmung vor lassen aber deswegen noch
mal so zur verdeutlichung also absolut
gar nicht bei uns hat er sonst eher
andere faktoren weswegen wir uns ärgern
über mitspieler und nicht weil
irgendetwas kaputt macht sondern über
falsche absprachen und solche sachen
die in der konfi passieren zum beispiel
wenn wir eine konnte überschreiben was
eigentlich nicht nach außen dringen soll
wenn dann ein mitspieler zum beispiel
was twitter zum beispiel das sind das
rückgrat in der konfi geschrieben so was
zum beispiel dass du das so etwas was
uns persönlich stört und ich wenn die
arbeitgeber das kann man also auf pole
zeit einfach im spiel
aber wenn private informationen oder
sowas einfach weiter gesagt werden als
beispiel das ist zum beispiel sache die
finde ich persönlich würde mich auch in
rheda von berger es wird also als
beispiel versteht ist dank ihren
geheimnis weiter und solche sachen
das sind so die sachen und deswegen also
außerdem falls ihr jetzt die sorge hat
okay den aus neue projekt auch wieder
kaputt keine sorge wenn da irgendwas
kaputt machen sollte gibt es bei uns
weil es wird es wird nicht mehr so
larifari regeln geben richter geben und
es wird hart entschieden und es wird
zwar scheint entschieden ist das wird so
sein dass ein richter zu einer gewissen
prozentzahl eine entscheidung fällt und
dann noch die zuschauer vielleicht auch
so dass dieser trend sei damit ja auch
mal dabei sein könnte es mit entscheiden
können sagte immer wenn die vandals wenn
wir die zuschauer sagen ganz ganz klar
dass es absolut dagegen dass er solche
ja nein um fragen wie man dann einfach
machen kann ja sie habe davon erst
einmal gelaufen aber ich find's ganz gut
hat mädchen wieder alles verraten ich
denke ich schon wieder ein paar sachen
gehört was wir so machen und so weiter
und was vielleicht eine idee ist und
nichts wie marseille läuft das projekt
auf jeden fall solltet ihr wert da viel
viel mehr mitspracherecht haben als ziel
bei mega projekt ihr wert da so viel
entscheiden können weil ich finde es
ganz wichtig gerade bei youtube ist ist
ja der unterrichtung im fernsehen wir
möchten etwas machen womit ihr euch
immer einbringen könnte das ist das was
unser ziel wir wollen gemeinsam schaffen
wir können nicht wir können nichts sagen
ihr könnt alle mitspieler 2000 aber
insgesamt weit über eine million oder
zwei millionen abonnenten bei allen
mitspielern geht das natürlich nicht ist
klar wir können euch sagen okay der eine
kann mitspielen und die anderen 2000
können ich will spielen das ist so eine
sache das kann man ganz ganz schwierig
machen aber so an entscheidungen
teilhaben lassen und solche sachen
da wollen wir euch einfach so gerne
mitnehmen einfach weil ihr seid
diejenigen für die spd wir das alles
machen ihr seid die zuschauer und das
ist ihr seid glaubt dass gar nicht wie
wichtig wir euch einfach finden wäre ich
nicht hier für und seid nur durch euch
existieren wir quasi ja und das muss
endlich vergessen also nowitzki haben
dafür dass ihr einfach auf eure
meinungen konnten macht und so die leute
die ihre meinung gut in die kommentare
schreiben
damit so ein respekt und es gibt
natürlich immer diese leute schreiben
dünner
das was du gemacht dass die heute
moderner mutter in buchbach solche leute
ja solche leute das sind dann genau dass
sich das schlechte beispiel dafür für
die kommentare und deswegen wird auch
immer so oft gesagt hatte youtube
kommentar dies ist aber wir wissen eben
dass es nicht nur solche leute gibt die
grüne großteil von euch sind vernünftige
leute das ist das fragt warum erst
machen wir wir lieben das einfach dass
ihr alles für euch zu machen und dann
mit euch gemeinsam über solche sachen zu
diskutieren warum schreiben wir bei
facebook jeden tag so viel krampf in der
warum sagen wir mal am ende was haltet
ihr davon wieder eure meinung dazu warum
machen wir das weil wir eben kenntlich
machen
wir wollen eben keinen fernseher also
bleiben wir wollen dass wir wollen euch
immer mit einbeziehen weil das das worum
es uns geht
wir haben bei den ganzen zuschauer
treffen mit so vielen leuten darüber
geredet dass die haben das mega
präpariert es ging ja wie geht's ein
baum aus wie geht es den us news und so
das ist so lustig ich finde es einfach
nur cool und da sie glauben sie an eine
einzige person hat uns gesagt da hat
insgesamt den [ __ ] sondern raus aus
dem megaprojekt keine
einige personen von dem über weit über
1000 die wir getroffen haben und
gamescom video day keine einzige was war
und das ist einfach dass wir dahin
community auf um mit dem wir was somit
auf die wir zählen
deswegen suchen wir immer wieder neue
möglichkeit neue projekte um die
community so einzubeziehen
das wäre meine ganze schaffen können so
und und auch das jetzt mit denen mit den
1000 folgen oder so sagt überhaupt
nichts gegen bremen sagte wissen keine
kommt so also ich persönlich finde es
super geil also in jedem fall war erst
gemeint das ist respekt davor ist der
1000 folgen das ich gemacht aber dann
war ich scharf und können da wir
schaffen das mega projekt können wir
nicht 1000 folgen lang machen wir haben
weit über 1000 folge aber die jeder
einzelne person kann 1000 voll gemacht
und in vielleicht haben wir irgendwann
ein projekt vielleicht das nächste
projekt vielleicht auch danach ein break
das haben wir ein projekt was vielleicht
1000 folgen
wir werden auf jeden fall eine sache
können wir versprechen wir können
vielleicht jetzt nicht versprechen des
megaprojekts 1400 weiß noch nicht aber
wir können versprechen dass wir immer
wieder neue projekte neue let's place
und regelmäßige serie machen lange mit
ihr nach hause kommt gute unterhaltung
habt und das versprechen das versprechen
aber ich ein hauptpunkt ist natürlich
auch dass wir dabei dann immer spaß
haben und ihr spaß an dem projekt haben
dann kannst du lang gehen wie wir wollen
und auch wenn ihr natürlich auch aktiv
dabei sind das sind immer so ein paar
faktoren die da natürlich
zusammenstellen müssen und für mich wäre
es für einer der größten wünsche dass
wir mal ein projekt finden wo wir
wirklich 1000 als beispiel 1000 folgen
dran so viel spaß haben also bei jedem
gehen hey was er denkt macht ja der und
zwar nicht so höhe der dass eine luft
gesprengt und höhe da wo das und das
gemacht aber man weiß nicht wer das war
stell dir vor wie lang rund 1000 vollen
saßen drei jahre drei jahre leute wenn
man nur will schafft dann kann man schon
echt stolz seine drei jahre das wird
wenn man irgendwo mein projekt haben was
das über ninja oder über mehrere jahre
gehen leute mit euch gemeinsam es wäre
unser großer traum aber das wäre wohl
erich geht jetzt schon vier monate fast
das ist auch eine immens lange zeit
schönste super geil ich finde wir haben
einfach alle gemeinsam gemacht und es
sind natürlich sachen passiert die nicht
so gewannen sind aber viele viele
vielmehr geile sachen passiert und wir
sollten nicht wir sollten auf gar keinen
fall den schleier darüber fallen lassen
was mir dabei zugucken dass das dass das
passiert ist sollen darüber denken was
alles passiert ist das immer im leben so
man denkt immer die negativen sachen
viel mehr nach als über die positiven
aber warum muss man sich immer alles nur
negativ machen warum sollte man sich
einfach mal im leben wir die sachen
gedanken machen wie er einmal
am tag vor und ihr war zb über den
schönen essen ihr wart mit dem unterwegs
selbst gekauft aber danach scheidet opel
aus jacke ja genau dann denkt ihr euch
scheiß mir den vogel aber ihr erzählt
nicht ja ich hab hier so'n schön burger
gegessen und was alles hat der burger
gegessen und sowas oder wie den also
doppel schnitzel oder so ja irgendwie
sowas electric gar nicht nach deswegen
denkmal die mega protest einfach mal wie
viel spaß wir hatten was ist alles
schönes gab
ich meine die outdoor sache weil auch
mal ganz witzig und so was alles vor
allem einfach geregelt reden darüber als
wäre es sozusagen zu ende ist aber nicht
mochte gar keine sorgen zu machen
wir reden kraft sich darüber dass es zu
ende so soll nicht einmal darüber klar
werden sich all das soll jetzt nicht
jetzt alles so schlechte ziehen so nur
weil eine explosion passiert ist oder so
wir fahren wirklich mein abgang ja ich
habe wirklich mal gesagt was was uns auf
dem herzen liegt und so bei ihr etwas
einfach enorm wichtig und das ist sache
der du bist du wieder am ende dran weil
wir schon wieder so figuriert vermutlich
ich wollte extra weniger reden aber aber
im land gutgeht
dieser hub sowohl die kann jetzt noch
brockens dabei ist einfach und doch mal
die maschinen witze erzählen
das wäre nochmal ein super abschluss für
die ganze folge ein jäger im wald hat
eine sniper
ich hab' ich sagen ja
verschiedene trifft beide 8 ok
durch die erste beschließt durch
geflogen ist überlebt die zweite stirbt
warum überlebt die zweite die erste mal
das geht durch die erste durch dann
müsste sie ja eigentlich kaputt sein
dank trifft die zweite die geht auch
kaputt aber raum ist die erste nicht
kaputt erschienen leben leben länger mit
ja verdammt sind damit und morgen geht
es dann weiter mit dem megaprojekt haut
rein und hoffentlich wieder so eine ganz
normale folge aber das musste einfach
mal gesagt werden und wir lieben und
stimmt uns zu freuen
da machst du das nächste mal machst du
wenn ihr euch alle job